[Music]
this is an eight news now severe weather
alert
well good thursday morning i'm sheri
swense good 8 news now weather center
right here we've been following
thunderstorms popping up in the valley
this morning dropping some rain even
some hail but also some very dangerous
lightning looking out to spring valley
in the southwest right now you can see
that storm cloud this is it on radar and
there has been a lot of lightning with
these cells as they've been moving from
east to west across the valley dropping
some rain but they've been moving pretty
quickly which is good news because that
means it doesn't pose a threat of flash
flooding but the cells earlier this
morning over here in the southwest right
around rhodes ranch
picked up nearly a tenth of an inch of
rain now these pop-up cells kind of came
out of nowhere we were looking at partly
cloudy skies and then all of a sudden
lightning even some hail out in the
southeast valley at paradise park
neighborhood so we continue to see these
they stay alive in the spring mountains
and are moving over into the front
valley dew points have been rising we
went from low 50s now to mid 60s more
moisture in the air
80s right now for temperatures and
humidity that's up near 50 percent we're
going to keep the threat of some
isolated thunderstorms for the next
couple of hours and then partly cloudy
mid morning with about 90s mid 90s that
hour 102 by noon and our last day of
heat warnings with 106 for your thursday
afternoon stay cool and hydrated today
we'll talk about the threat of flooding
in your weekend forecast